[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا تتواصل في المدن المغربيه في
مراكز الاقتراع تتواصل عمليات فرز الاصوات
في عموم هذه المراكز بعد اغلاقها في
الساعه السابعه من مساء هذا اليوم
بالتوقيت المحلي هنا وقد اعلنت وزاره
الداخليه المغربيه ان نسبه المشاركه
المؤقته حتى ساعه اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع
وصلت الى حدود
43% اذا نسبه المشاركه بحسب وزاره
الداخليه المغربيه اي حوال
43% تنافس في هذه الانتخابات التي جرت
اليوم
32 حزبا
تنافسوا للفوز بمقاعد البرلمان والبالغ
عددها
395 مقعدا وكما هو معروف فان القانون
المغربي ينص على تعيين رئيس الحكومه من
بين اعضاء الحزب الحاصل على اكبر عدد من
المقاعد ومعنا من طنجه مراسلنا احمد جرار
هو هناك يتابع نتائج عمليات الفرز في
مراكز الاقتراع في طنجه احمد ما هي اخر
المعلومات بالنسبه لعمليات الفرز المستمره
حتى
اللحظه نعم نحن الان نتواجد في ثانويات
ابي العباس السبتي وهي احدى المدارس في
مدينه طنجه وتحديدا في حي ابن بطوطه في
هذه المدرسه تجري من خلف في ربما اللمسات
الاخيره لعمليه فرز الاصوات في هذه
المدرسه كان يوجد عدد من الصناديق تم
فرزها بشكل اولي ومن ثم هنا يتم الفرز
بشكل رسمي وبشكل نهائي حاليا اللجان من
خلفي تقوم بعمليه الفرز النهائي وبحضور
طبعا مراقبين وبحضور مندوبي لجان ال
مندوبين عن غالبيه الاحزاب المشاركه في
هذه الانتخابات في مدينه طنجه بشكل عام في
مدينه طنجه وصل بحسب تقديرات الشبه
الرسميه فان نسبه التصويت وصلت الى نحو
30% من مجموع الناخبين المسجلين طبعا وهذه
النسبه هي اعلى بنحو 88% من النسبه التي
سجلت في الانتخابات الماضيه انا للاقتراب
اكثر من المشهد الانتخابي المغربي هنا في
مدينه طنجه قمت بحضور عمليه فرز لاحد
الصناديق منذ اول من اول ورقه الى اخر
ورقه في هذا الصندوق كان يوجد 300
235 صوتا طبعا كان هناك عمليه فرز مشرف
اللجان يقوم كان بعرض كل ورقه على حده على
مندوبي الاحزاب ويخبرهم بعمليه لمن سيتم
احتساب هذا الصوت طبعا كان هناك بعض
الاوراق التي تم الغائها اما لوجود اكثر
من التاشير على اكثر من قائمه واما لوجود
عبارات اخرى ليس لها علاقه بالانتخابات
يعني احدى
الاصوات صاحبها صوت لالتراس احد الفرق
المحليه لكن بحسب هذه الصناديق حضرت عمليه
الفرز حتى نهايتها حصل حزب العداله
والتنميه على 129 صوتا ومن ثم الاصاله
والمعاصره على 26 صوتا ومن ثم حزب الاتحاد
الدستوري على 16 صوتا طبعا وفي في باقي
الصناديق كانت النتائج الى حد ما متقاربه
اي طبعا هذا كل هي فقط عمليه يعني هي
صناديق اربع صناديق من اصل عدد كبير من
الصناديق في مدينه طنجه لا نستطيع ان نقدم
اي مؤشرات هذه الارقام التي شاهدناها
وتابعنا من خلال متابعه احدى عمليات الفرز
هنا في ثانويه ابي العباس السبتي في مدينه
طنجه نعم بالتاكيد احمد هذه الارقام حتى
اللحظه لا يمكن لا يمكن اعتمادها على انها
اي ارقام تعبر عن الاتجاهات العامه لنتائج
هذه الانتخابات لكنها تبقى ارقام ارقام في
داخل الصناديق جرى فرزها وشهدت عليها
اشكرك جزيلا احمد جرار من طنجه وانتقل
الان الى عبد المنعم العمراني من الرباط
ماذا لديك عبد المنعم على صعيد عمليات
الفرز في مراكز الاقتراع في الرباط
والمحيط نعم نعم حسن العمليه كما يعرف
الجميع الان عمليه التصويت انتهت في
التوقيت الذي كان محددا حضرنا عمليه اغلاق
باب المكتب احد مكاتب التصويت هنا في
مدينه الرباط في دائره الرباط شال وحضرنا
جزءا من عمليه الفرز مع جمع كبير من
الصحفيين والكاميرات وهذه الى حد ما سابقه
ربما في في في المغرب الى الى حد ما ولو
انها ليست ليست بجديده كان كانت العمليه
تمت بشكل
شفاف كان هناك ايضا وجود لمراقبين من
المجلس الوطني لحقوق الانسان الذي يشرف
على عمليه توزيع المراقبين في عدد من
المكاتب التصويت لملاحظه ومراقبه عمليه
التصويت من بدايتها الى نهايتها الى بما
في ذلك عمليه الفرز وايضا كان هناك حضور
لممثلي بعض الاحزاب الذين كانوا يدققون مع
رئيس المكتب ونائبه العمليه بخطوه خطوه
كما يعرف الجميع ايضا وكما ذكرت ذكرت
اعتقد في المقدمه نسبه المشاركه ما زالت
مؤقته حددتها وزاره الداخليه المغربيه في
43% عند الساعه عند الساعه السابعه ساعه
اغلاق مراكز التصويت لكن طبعا هناك هناك
تفاوت على مستوى الجهات فمثلا في بعض
الجهات الجنوبيه هذه النسبه ترتفع الى
حدود 50% وتقل بكثير في بعض المدن الكبرى
بشمال المملكه خاصه في مدينه الدار
البيضاء وايضا في مدن اخرى ولكن طبعا كل
هذا سابق لاوانه ننتظر الليله في حدود
منتصف الليل بالتوقيت المغربي الساعه
الثانيه صباحا بتوقيت الدوحه تصريحا صحفيا
لوزير الداخليه المغربي سيعطي في ارقام
ومعطيات نهائيه او شبه نهائيه لعمليه
التصويت التي تمت هذا اليوم
حسن شكرا لك عبد المنعم العمراني من
الرباط والى الدار البيضاء مع امال والناس
والتي تابعت طوال هذا اليوم عمليات
الاقتراع الان هي تتابع عمليات الفرز ايضا
في الدار البيضاء ماذا لديك
امل
حسن امال يبدو انها انها لا
تسمعنا سنعود اليها بالتاكيد في سياق هذه
النافذه لمتابعه ايضا عمليات الفرز في
الدار البيضاء لكن الان معنا ضيفنا هنا في
استديو التغطيه في الرباط الاستاذ الجامعي
والمحلل
السياسي الموسوي العجلاوي مرحبا بك سيد
الموسوي نسبه المشاركه التي اعلنتها وزاره
الداخليه بحدود
43% هل تتوافق مع هذا الجو المحموم
والحملات الانتخابيه والاستقطاب السياسي
الحاد الذي سبق هذا اليوم الانتخابي
الطويل مهما يكون النسبه التي ات عنها
وزاره الداخليه حوالي
43% تقارب ما اعن عنه في العام
2011 السؤال المطروح فيما يخص الاجواء
التي جرت ان في العام 2011 كان هناك دستور
جديد كان هناك امل بالقفز بالتجربه
الديمقراطيه الى الامام الان
هناك نوع من الاستقطاب الثنائي الحاد بين
حزبين مغربيين كبيرين ربما هي نفس الظروف
وهذا ربما ايضا ما يفسر لماذا نسبه
المشاركه تجاور ال 45% كما هو الحال
بالنسبه للعام 2011 فليست هناك مفاجاه كان
منتظرا ان تصل نسبه المشاركه الى هذا
العدد نظرا
تغيرت بطبيعه الحال الظروف ولكن النسبه
بقيت هي هذه وهذا ما يفسر على ان التجربه
المغربيه في اطار النظام السياسي القائم
يتيح هذه العمليه مستوى التنافس مستوى حتى
بعض تحدثنا غير ما مر عن ضربات تحت الحزام
ولكن كل ذلك ممكن ان نضعه في اطار ما يمكن
نسميه بحمه انتخابيه لكن الاطار العام
فيما يخص النظام السياسي فيما يخص نظام
الاقتراع فيما يخص ايضا مساله مساهمه
الاحزاب السياسيه تضل كما هي وهذا ما يعطي
نوع من استقرار على مستوى طيب كيف يمكن ان
تفهم الاحزاب السياسيه التي شاركت في هذه
الانتخابات كيف يمكن ان تفهم هذا الرقم
لنسبه المشاركه والذي هو 43%
43% بمعنى اقل من 8 ملايين من المغاربه
نساء وذكورا شاركوا في في هذه العمليه هو
درس بليغ لان من المفروض ان تكون نسبه
اكثر من 50% لان هناك دستور جديد هناك
ولايه كان يجب محاسبه
من تحملوا مسؤوليه الخمس السنوات هناك
ايضا نوع من نقاش سياسي الحاد داخل بين
الطبقه السياسيه هذه الاشياء كلها كان من
المفروض ان تؤدي الى ارتفاع النسبه على
اكثر مما جرى في 2011 ولكن يبدو ان السقف
التعبئه بالنسبه للاحزاب المغربيه لا
يتعدى نصف المسجلين علما يجب ان ننتظر
الاوراق البيضاء ان ننتظر ايضا الاوراق
الملغاه الاوراق التي لم تحسب حتى يمكن
تقييم عمليه المشاركه وعمليه ايضا توزيع
الاصوات على الاحزاب التي ساهمت في هذا
الانتخاب اشكرك جزيلا الموسوي العجلاوي
الاستاذ الجامعي والمحلل
السياسي مشاهدينا اعود بكم الى امال
والناس مراسله الجزيره في الدار البيضاء
لتعطينا فكره عن عمليات فرز الاصوات في
مراكز الاقتراع في المدينه الثانيه في
المغرب العاصمه الاقتصاديه للبلاد الدار
البيضاء
امال نعم حسن ت وصل عمليه فرز الاصوات هنا
في الدار البيضاء المسؤول الاعلامي في
محافظه الدار البيضاء كان صرح لنا بانه
يتوقع ان يتم الاعلان عن نتائج اوليه
رسميه خاصه بالدار البيضاء في حدود الساعه
الحاد ع اي بعد اقل من ساعتين من الان
كذلك بمجرد البداء في عملي الفرز حاولنا
الاتصال بالعديد من المرشحين او وكلاء
اللوائح الانتخابيه لاحزاب متنافسه ما
يمكن استخلاص من الحوارات التي اجريناها
معهم انه لا نستطيع الان الجازم بتقدم حزب
على اخر وان الوقت لا يزال مبكرا
احد احد المرشحين اكد لنا بان المحاضر
التي تم فرزها حتى الان قليله جدا وان
اظهر تقدم حزبه لن اذكره حاليا ولكن لا لا
يزال الوقت مبكرا للجزم بتقدم هذا الحزب
عن ذاك خلال العمليه التصويت هذا اليوم
كانت مصادره محليه هنا في الدار البيضاء
تحدثت عن تلقيها شكاوى من وكلاء من وكلاء
او رؤساء لوائح انتخابيه وحزب بشان وجود
خروقات قد اضرت بسير العمليه الانتخابيه
ولكن وزاره الداخليه وكذلك مصادر محليه
هنا في محافظه الدار البيضاء اكدت ان هذه
الشكاوى وصفتها بالكيد وانه لم تسجل لديها
ايه خروقات ممكن او كفيله بالاضرار او
بعرق العمليه عمليه الاقتراع هذا
اليوم عمليه الاقتراع عموما تمت بطريقه
سلسه وبنسبه للمشاركه نسبه المشاركه لم
تظهر بعد نسبه رسميه نهائيه هنا في الدار
البيضاء ولكن يتوقع ان تفوق النسبه
38% اشكرك جزيلا امل والناس من الدار
البيضاء
بهذا مشاهدينا ناتي الى ختام هذه النافذه
المخصصه للانتخابات التشريعيه المغربيه
طبعا سوف نتابع نتائج عمليات الفرز وايضا
نتائج النتائج النهائيه
لهذه الانتخابات في نشرات ونوافذ اخرى
تابعونا وعوده الان الى رلا وجلال في
الدوحه